so this was my first time in it just
meeting them as soon as we walk in jokes
bagging
right feel like we've been knowing each
other for years bros you know what i
mean and um
[Music]
jay worthy had already started on a song
so the competitiveness in me woke up
inside i'm hot oh this [ __ ]
what all right so now it's like
we basically in my mind i didn't say it
out loud i don't know what he was
thinking but every time something come
on
i'm trying to get on there first that's
why sometimes you hear him first
sometimes you hear me first that's like
who right at that time i was still
writing my raps
and then while we doing this cardo
um polyester diamond ortiz they over
there making the beats so we did all
that [ __ ] in one night one night then
the next the next day we did the album
cover you know what i'm saying wow so
this was like a one night process you
know what i mean and we was just all in
there just we joking having a good time
but just the aggressive competitive
spirit was also there and that [ __ ] was
till this day that's like some of my top
streaming [ __ ] that's what everybody you
know a lot of yeah
got had a great run just doing full
projects with people and yeah
you know running it up larry yeah he
just drops up with larry june right last
friday yeah carter was amazing man he
just he got it's something about him man